there's no hiding anything in those
suits I don't think that I was quite
prepared for how exposed you are and
walking around and I was okay because at
least mine was black the only thing to
do really at that juncture is just to
laugh laugh at yourself laugh at the
situation I was kind of fun it was
Gillian South Station is great playing
Rachel McLaren the daughter about Rob
Bishop who's play they got a old man she
was a good sport
we ran around did all these crazy motion
sets with her and she was game for
everything it was made extremely
friendly and comfortable very very
quickly by the other actors and by the
director and and the crew put your ego
at the door
and just have fun really good actors and
have fun with them and try and get some
of that magic into the digital world
there's another day ping coming stay
short you know I look like sandy the
squirrel from Sponge Bob is too strange
to be doing you know very very serious
scenes with serious actors when you look
like that whatever technology was
attached to us is picking up every
single emotion it really kind of focuses
your mind on that this is a serious
situation you've also got Gary Hall for
the mark Strong yeah we were going
through a list of actresses that we
thought will be believable as Gary's
daughter and that strong person that
would be able to lead the ship because
you have to believe that this person is
in command and is confident you know all
the things that I think Jillian can do
really well never gets old does it sir
Yeti's okay so we're gonna have Gary on
the set and her but Gary will be at his
station and she'll be at her station
that really Gary's on the bridge of the
- Gary and Jillian's on the bridge of
the gauntlet I ordered you to fall back
do that huh you're dead in the water and
we can help you you know I will miss the
plywood furniture and on the TV it was
already surrounded by the ship as it
will look that it's just completely new
for me and I think a lot of people - it
took a lot of kind of explain oh no
don't you get it that's what was going
on here and everybody who goes there gun
handling is much better than like I
guess yeah she looked good I mean like
you could capture the combat say I think
I held a gun on the fall but when I used
to shoot guns on the x-files
you know it was a Sig Sauer it was a you
know proper issue metal heavy gun and
these were pieces of wood stuck thinking
if they're painted quick I shot at huge
aliens initially you know I was running
around in my suit mmm shooting to agree
and then Chris and hang on let me show
you what these guys you see that's
actually the size of the creatures so
they're pretty big yes
well I had a huge amount of fun and it
wasn't embarrassing enough to not come
back again
it's a great day yeah I was probably
amazing and I think that we come true to
innocent marines and aliens and it's fun
to have like great actors and also
people you've sort of seen growing up
they're gonna bring the world alive and
I think it'll be an experience that
people haven't had in the game buddy
Falls I think will make the world much
more immersive